workin a gang spot offers me a lot of
luxuries I get to talk about games I get
to make videos of bad games and
sometimes I get to play games before
they're even out sometimes these games
are exciting and great sometimes they're
boring but usually people only watch the
previews if they're already interested
in that game this is why sites like ours
don't really do previews that much
anymore but I'm taking a swing at this
one because genuinely overwatch is a
game that after you play you can't wait
to tell people about okay let's break it
down right now there are a bunch of
first-person MOBA style games with
generic as [ __ ] titles coming out and
most of them are struggling for
attention gearbox had massive battle
born stages at every game event this
year to try and get the word out
Bethesda is currently evaluating battle
cry after the studio has raised some
concerns with their new IP while
blizzards first attempt at a shooter
since vaporware legends starcraft ghost
is also struggling to get eyes on people
are skeptical like myself and whiteley
so there are a lot of similar-looking
first-person experiences all coming at
once and I get it I'm an FPS guy who
doesn't like MOBAs in any game that
refers to its characters as heroes it's
going to be looked at with some
skepticism by me so as somebody who grew
up on PC first-person shooters if
there's one thing I want you to learn
from this video it's an overwatch is a
great game it may be a fantastic game
it's likely going to be absolutely huge
and if I was a betting man I'd even say
it might be a challenger to CS go for
first person eSport du jour but I'm
getting a bit ahead of myself I've been
keeping an eye on overwatch for the past
12 months and I got to play it again a
few days ago so in this video let me
explain why first-person PC fans should
have this game on their radar how it
feels like a new type of multiplayer and
why if this game doesn't launch
free-to-play I'll eat my hat
okay top level over watches an
online-only first-person shooter where
teams of six be six battle for dominance
across a variety of asymmetric maps
imagine team fortress 2 but with a lot
more characters and less important
centered on shot accuracy specifically
currently the roster includes 18 unique
characters everything from a huge ape to
a Zen robot to a time warping british
lady each character has a weapon and a
bunch of powers but they basically fall
into four classes offense defense tank
at support nothing new here right
characters classes unique abilities got
it now remember this is a blizzard game
the folks who made Starcraft this is a
finely tuned game where no one character
can win a match each has a strength but
the team's overall strength is judged
not by the skill of each player but by
the character they're picking and the
strategy they employ and boy does this
game have a lot of satisfying strategy
generally speaking each character has a
weapon some powers a unique movement
ability and then an ultimate ability
which is charged by taking and giving
damage so an example of this would be
the big lad Reinhardt he's got a hammer
as a weapon he has a shield barrier on a
projectile fast as his powers his
movement ability is a charge and his
ultimate is a big ground stone so he's
pretty powerful on his own and can
generally lead the charge with his
hammer and shield even if he's a bit
slow however couple him with somebody
like Lucy oh and you've got something
else entirely this crazy brazilian
support class has a pretty weak gun but
his suit has speakers on it which are
capable of pumping out music that makes
people faster or regenerates their
health he can also give this a boost
with one of his powers plus he's able to
wall right around the map to avoid fire
and get to other teammates in need
however couple these two dudes together
and you have a massive ax-wielding
shield which is capable of both
sprinting really fast and healing itself
and this is just one combination in a
game with 18 characters and asymmetric
maps with evolving strategies overwatch
is that game full of this type of
strategy combinations of players against
combinations of other players the same
thing that DOTA and leaf players go
crazy about but in a genuinely fantastic
feeling shooter it's not just about
shooting the other person in the face
the difference between winning
losing it is how well your team adapts
to the constantly evolving battleground
you are playing this game with the
roster in mind and swapping out
characters for a winning strategy is an
incredibly satisfying experience teams
win matches and Blizzard a determined to
get that point across you see everything
in this game is tailored towards team
play last hits are recorded but it takes
a village to murder another village many
people came towards each enemies
elimination so each person involved is
rewarded there's no traditional score
screen saying who's killed the most
people at the top and who's killed the
least at the bottom instead a variety of
contributing metrics are recorded
unrewarded so it's not just kills that
are rewarded you get recognized for
things like most damage taken and most
teleported but be careful if you are an
infra at your player because the game
will highlight this for the other team
while the endgame screen gives you an
opportunity to give props to the best
players overwatch is a really fun game
to play but it also has some areas which
might turn out to be problematic first
of all these game modes are nothing new
it is some standard point capture maps
and a mode which is basically payload
for Team Fortress 2 it also has some
hero balancing to be done I tried to
play as every character but when our
team was getting pinned back I'd swapped
a walking turret bastion and sweep up as
many kills as I could and as a team game
it's also one that requires a lot of
communication and though Blizzard have
created a communication wheel for those
who don't have headsets as well finally
be in the beta really success depends on
whether or not you pair up with a team
of players willing to coordinate to that
point with 6v six games weak links can
ruin your team we had a couple of games
where one or two bad players meant we
were totally blown over by the
opposition basically like a MOBA so
hopefully Blizzard can use their
matchmaking tech to solve this problem
and if MOBA is a dirty word in the world
of video games that Blizzard is trying
desperately to avoid it's not the only
one game designer Jeff Kaplan still has
no answer on the game's pricing model
but the type of game this is in the
success of hero sales and other MOBAs
means everything points to free-to-play
I can imagine a world in which 18 heroes
and three game modes would be an
acceptable jumping-off point for this
game but until we see their exact plans
the jury is still out but overall
overwatch is genuinely something to get
excited about
lizard are good at one thing it's
communicating complicated mechanisms to
players lizard made me half good at
starcraft two lizard got me into MMOs
with world the war ground an overwatch
is a layered first-person shooter which
is an absolute blast to explore if
you're a fan of team fortress 2 or
counter-strike it does scratch that
shooter edge while the hero variety and
strategic options translate the best
aspects of competitive MOBAs the first
person if you're at all interested make
sure you opt into the closed beta which
is starting out later this month and if
you have any more questions about the
game stick it in the comments or hit me
up on twitter at daniel dwyer for more
coverage of overwatch stay tuned to
gamespot and i'll just leave you with
this clip of me destroying a bunch of
fellow twitch streamers see ya